Faust was the mythical figure who sold
his soul to the devil for unlimited
power now remember that Japan has no
energy resources of its own it does not
have oil does not have coal has a little
bit of hydropower so it is dependent on
nuclear energy to keep that economy
going and that economy is huge we're
talking about the third largest economy
on the face of the earth but what does
an economy like that mean if it's based
on nuclear and when tsunami can simply
wipe out scores of nuclear power plants
this is going to force every
industrialized nation to reevaluate the
Faustian bargain Germany has already
announced that it may begin the process
of closing down reactors in that country
in the United States we also have a
crisis because we have old reactors just
like in Japan in the United States we
haven't had a new order for a nuclear
power plant since before Three Mile
Island 1979 we're dealing with really
old reactors and they have to be
decommissioned this means that the
United States is undergoing a sea change
with regards to a new generation of
power plants what will replace all these
aging nuclear power plants we may even
have to rethink whether or not nuclear
is the best option at all because the
question is let's say that the Fukushima
reactor was new could it withstand 9.0
and the answer is probably no so even if
you were to brace a reactor even if you
were to add more redundant safety
systems I doubt that it could withstand
a one-two punch from a 9.0 earthquake
and tsunami think of driving a car
driving a car that's out of control what
do you do you hit the brakes
well the brakes don't work it's still
out of control and then the radiator
blows up and you say to yourself oh my
god next is the gas tank the gas tanks
gonna go what do you do you run it into
a river that's exactly what they did in
Japan first the brakes didn't work
because the tsunami wiped out the backup
system then the core is heated up cause
a hydrogen gas explosion
that's your radiator blowing up and then
when they do they ran it into the river
that's the same thing as dumping
seawater on these nuclear power plants
and of course to keep the seawater going
you have to have power and they don't
have power and meanwhile radiation
levels rise to the point where it's near
lethal so you're caught in this bind
even if that reactor was a new reactor
so some people are saying maybe we
should rethink our commitment to nuclear
at all